just to take a look at it here 9
15 great shot from our crew 9 15 that's
what it looked like look at all the snow
in the ice
and now it's ready for baseball amazing
transformation
and an incredible job by some incredibly
dedicated people
right-hander michael former he's making
his second start and boy oh boy was he
good
last time out he went five innings he
recorded his first win
in quite some time and it was a dominant
performance he was uh
very very good i was extremely impressed
with the velocity of his fastball
he's out there in short sleeves on a
chilly day just because
a lot of pitchers don't like wearing the
long sleeve but michael
had all his pitches working hopefully
today he'll be able to get the grip and
spin on his breaking ball because he had
a very good slide or two
and uh he's looking for back-to-back
wins seven pitches two away here's brian
reynolds
fastball strike three called he got him
on the inside corner with a power
96 mile an hour sinker all going to be
facing left-hander tyler anderson he's
making his first start
he's the guy that's never faced the
tigers so it'll be a new experience for
all tiger hitters
and his average fastballs the eighth
slowest among starters and nationally at
87.3 miles an hour has gone 2-0
count and only four or 64 betters robbie
grossman
220 average with a homer and four runs
batted in
and it takes care of grossman to start
another off-speed pitch for strike three
on the 3-2 count it's
that's what you get with anderson is he
is
a complete pitcher he doesn't care what
the count is
he's got command of everything he throws
so you can't look for anything
there's no such thing as being in a
fastball count with him and so one out
nico goodrum hitless in his last ten
right now anderson
with a couple of strikeouts to start
candelario now at the plate next pitch
is swung on and missed
he strikes out the side in order tyler
anderson
putting a foot down early as we go to
the second seven up seven down for
michael former
the wind up the o2 swinging a miss man
is this good stuff
jimmy he's dealing right now curveball
looks good that was a
dynamite slider over the middle of the
plate tell you what we've seen that
a yellow hammer from him the fastball at
96.
the movement outstanding ate up eight
down
32 pitches swinging a soft ground ball
to third charging backhanding short
guns it over to scope a perfect chest
high strike on the first ground ball
that he fields in the major leagues yes
sir baby
zach short takes care of kevin newman
and
again michael fulmer takes care of the
pirates nine
up nine down through three it is rare
to get to this point in the game without
a single base runner
reyes sprays one down the right field
line polanco drifting over plays it in
front and then bobbles it
reyes on his way to second base he
cruises in and the tigers have the lead
off man on here in the third
tries to pull the ball in and that
probably would have held him but first
victor reyes didn't slow down so we'll
see what the ruling's going to be
and here's zach short with a chance to
drive in tigers first run in his first
major league at bat
and he draws a solid walk good for him
yeah mom and dad can exhale a little bit
here runners at the corners now
robbie grossman struck out looking on a
3-2 pitch in the first
driven to left-center on his horse's
fowler drifting over he's got it
reyes tags it's a sacrifice fly for
robbie grossman
the tigers have a one-nothing lead here
in the third sacrifice fly for robbie
grossman one-nothing tigers here in the
third well
you know really give that run to victor
reyes
got a base hit we've got the second base
in the air stole third
and robbie with a good at bat got a
picture he could do some damage with and
drove in the run that's
situational hitting and doing the job
the right way he got to extend good job
it's first and second with no one out
gives brian reynolds an opportunity to
tie the game he struck out looking on a
3-2 pitch in the first and a line drive
to right field and a base hit
and the runner is going to be waved home
and the throw will come toward
third it'll be cut off as reynolds
brings home frazier from second
evans to third it's tied at one
boy that's a quick answer
detroit able to put one across in the
bottom of the third in the top three of
the lineup after the pirates go hitless
through three bang bang bang that wasn't
a change up but a slider
brings up colin moran former pauses the
pitch ground ball
softly a diving stop by zach short he'll
pop up and throw to first
to get the batter moran into score
comes philip evans what a fine play by
zach short otherwise that ball is into
left field
softly for another hit instead it's a
simple force at second a run for the
pirates they have a 2-1 lead well that's
quick reaction with that young man
brian reynolds had an rbi single he is
at second base jacob stallings just
walked alan moran had an rbi
ground out robbed of a hit by the third
baseman zach short here's the pitch
poked out to left and gonzalez comes
through
reynolds in the score eric gonzalez with
a two out
rbi single didn't smoke it by any
stretch but got enough of it eric
gonzalez brings home reynolds from
second and now the pirates lead three to
one
and stalling stops at second base
well eric gonzalez um at times he can be
undisciplined you could see the free
swing uh
like he chased the first pitch of the
at-bat to slider but
this year so far in these situations boy
what a great job eric gonzalez has done
tigers trying to bounce back after the
three runs in the top half of this
inning have the pirates on top 3-1
jonathan scope boy this would do him a
world of good a big two out hit
ramos a runner at second scope trying to
deliver him with two outs
here in the fourth tigers down two of
the pitch swinging a shot up the middle
and pass to diving frazier into center
ramos around third coming home and he
will score without a throw
jonathan scope smoked it up the middle
and the tigers are within one down 3-2
well there you go there's your talk
about bat speed he got a fastball up in
the zone did not try to pull it
just a good solid swing he's not hit
lefties well but he doubled on a hanging
slider
his only time that he's faced terry
scuba first pitch swinging a ground ball
diving back here to stop by castro he'll
throw sitting down and he got him at
first what a play
willy castro lays out at second base
sitting down
throws a one hopper and scope scooped it
and the tigers hold the pirates off the
board in the top of the seventh
de reyes the switch hitter who is
batting
up to left-handed and fowler with room
and that's that richard rodriguez
secures the win
the pirates have won seven of ten
and they win this afternoon in game one
three to two
in detroit how about these pirates what
a great game this was